Wolverine gets locked in a prison cell
with a cannibal and it's every bit as
gruesome as you think it is okay so this
takes place in Wolverine issue number
165 as part of a story called The Hunted
but nothing else in this story is overly
important what is important here is that
this takes place in a prison called the
cage and because of a device Inside the
Cage that basically neutralizes people's
abilities Wolverine has no healing
Factor no enhanced senses and for
reasons that nobody can explain he
doesn't have access to his claws doesn't
make any sense right if you guys aren't
familiar with that check out a video
that we did called fatal attractions
which explains that whole thing that
goes on with his claws what is important
here is that in the prison there are
these guys that basically wake up this
dude named Mo and the whole idea behind
it is for this guy to off wolver rain
and there's a couple reasons for this
one because it's wolver rain right
everybody's trying to kill him all the
time but the other part of this is that
Inside the Cage are like a series of
rival gangs the two most prom minent or
at least the one that really applies the
most here is a group called the skulls
and they're literally just these crazy
guys who follow the ideologies of like
the Red Skull and so on and so forth but
the kicker about all this is that
Wolverine is currently confined in
What's called the hole literally a giant
hole in the prison like that's literally
what it is like solitary confinement if
you want to call it that he is met by a
guy named peepers now peepers is a
Morlock basically a mutant whose
abilities make him look physically
grotesque quote unquote and he can't
just live out there in the normal world
but he's kind of like an ally of
Wolverine who is also here which is kind
of cool so is Beast right Beast is here
as well he's got an image inducer which
actually gets rid of his Beast form and
makes them look human he's not overly
important in all of this what is
important here is that when Mo was woken
up that he initially goes after this
blonde guy right one of the people that
helped to wake him and one of the guards
draws a gun and he says here's the rup
right here's the deal in exchange for
taking out a guy that we have here we
will let you go free we will let you out
there in the world and do your thing now
the question has to be asked why do they
care about a cannibal because this guy
is not just any type of person like that
right in fact he actually gains
abilities based on how much he eats so
much so that in fact his resurrection
drew the attention of Doctor Strange so
it is kind of a cool thing that this is
happening right mystical Powers all that
kind of cool stuff now one of the other
things is happening here is that with
Wolverine locked in this prison you of
course have like Nick Fury and shield
who are basically preparing to
orchestrate a prison break so the thing
here that happens is that as Wolverine
is stuck down here in this hole the
guard shows up and then just like douses
him in what appears to be water for the
most part he's just kind of monologuing
to himself right just kind of having a
conversation and talking about how he
got himself in this rut and how he
brought Beast Down with him and all that
kind of crazy stuff right just sitting
around feeling bad for himself and so
one once he comes to and this guy starts
taunting him wolver R's like is that a
hose right is that like the best you
have and the guy's like why not ask your
friend McCoy he knows that we can do a
whole lot better of course taunting him
and basically saying we've done some
work on beast and he even goes so far as
to say that he's probably pushing up
daisies by about now right like maybe we
killed your friend maybe we didn't right
and then when Wolverine starts talking
back this guy says like watch your mouth
something you need to know that's not
water and that's when Wolverine starts
to realize he's basically been drugged
right like he's literally without his
healing Factor succumbing to all this
stuff and so what ends up happening is
that the kind of agreement that was made
between peepers and wolver rain which is
one of the reasons why I want to talk
about his character for a second is that
peepers would keep Hank McCoy safe he
would keep Beast safe from anybody out
there that wants to take him out
especially considering the fact that
wolver rain and Beast while they were in
this prison made life pretty rough for
the skulls one of the guys comes in and
tries to take Beast out but ultimately
you end up having uh PE persu steps in
and basically keeps bee safe and that's
effectively it now at that point
Wolverine wakes up in the prison cell
alongside Mo and this is where stuff
gets pretty hardcore right because he
says one moment it's been a while since
I've tasted this right tasted people I
nearly forgotten how truly refreshing it
is as for who I am my true name no
longer matters but you may as well call
me me that which I've been most often
referred to in my life Mo right which in
French translates to evil at least I
assume it does I failed French so he
says in truth I am but a fellow prisoner
condemned for my crimes and immovable
existence by the sorcerer Supreme of a
past era but yet another way to look at
me is as your executioner and literally
just starts taking it to Wolverine so
much so that like the guards are
watching this on unfold through like a
crack in the wall now MO is totally
aware of the fact that like this is
basically a ruse right like as soon as
he takes out Wolverine the guards are
probably going to try to kill him right
and so he's he's not by any means a dumb
guy and he even says that he's like they
believe I am unaware of the treachery
that they have in mind but it is they
who are unaware of the powers I possess
and the means by which I obtain them so
the first thing he does takes a chunk
out of wol rain right reaches out and
touches somebody that's exactly what he
does right takes a bite right out of
Wolverine's chest and then what you do
is you kind of jump forward by what
appears to be a few minutes and there's
just like all these chunks missing out
of it right just like all these pieces
that have basically been taken and it's
just kind of like man and the thing
about it is this guy is like just
salivating at it all right he says I
must say in all my years I have never
come across flesh so invigorating and
believe me coming from one whose
mystical powers are derived from the
consumption of of this meat that is a
great compliment indeed and so where
Wolverine kind of tries to talk trash a
little bit right he's like how about we
switch things up and I take a few chunks
out of you for a change the response of
Mo is like in time right like maybe
we'll get to that maybe we won't right
now I need to consume you so that I can
basically get out of here he says now
hold still this will only hurt a great
deal he literally reaches into
Wolverine's head and just pops that eye
right out and it's just dude it's nuts
it's I mean it's it's crazy that this
happened right it's crazy that Marvel
did this right and he says you see the
special properties of your flesh have
already partially rejuvenated my Powers
enough that I can sense others coming
and since I am still weakened from
Awakening I'd rather how do you say eat
and run so literally he eats Wolverine's
eye and bails right just like
immediately takes off it's kind of crazy
right it's one of the craziest things
that I've seen now what gets really
crazy about this is the way that it ends
and the reason why is because like the
warden and like this guy walks in and
they basically intend like because of
the fact that Wolverine's quote unquote
not necessarily dead it's just kind of
like okay like what do we do with this
guy like what do we do at this point
because he was supposed to be offed
right the ultimate decision they make is
to basically just do it themselves but
what ends up happening is like once
they've got this thing pointed at
Wolverine's face a claw comes out of
nowhere slashes these two guys from
behind and the one person wolver rain
never expected to see is standing there
Sabertooth is part of the team that's
been pulled together to get Wolverine
out of this prison with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
let me know what you guys think about
this this is a really crazy story pretty
short but it's really crazy and I will
catch you all later peace